former manager of the Orioles Rangers
Diamondbacks and the New York Yankees
Buck Showalter how you been buck
Richard how we looking great
better photography Yankee stay back
there games over a postgame show it's
about 20 degrees and you really get to
know somebody don't you yes you do yes
you do and also going through going
through security in Arizona trying to
get to New York and back and forth
during the flight you try to get through
security of that stuff in your suitcase
I know well also was 2001 and people
were just on their last nerve it was
quite a time a 2001 World Series we
covered together for ESPN what what you
know what's your memory of managing that
all-star game in 95 that must have been
yeah I mean well I mean I'm sure was hot
but it was also coming off the strike
and and it was kind of the the biggest
first national watched baseball game
post strike buck that must have been
something that all-star game yeah you
know it's funny this is the playoffs
against Seattle that year with us was I
remember a lot of people talking about
how it kind of rekindled their love for
baseball actually strike and I hope
people have a long memory of how bad
that strike was for our game when they
start heaviness to talk about Labor
problems because it's just it's kind of
like war there's nobody wins nobody wins
and I I remember we played a three or
four game set against the Rangers that
we I was here four or seven I was in
Texas for seven days
going over Six Flags Over Texas doing an
interview it was so hot I had three
first base I'm Homer Frank Thomas
welcome Bobby in the third inning going
out done planes leave and I go excuse me
see I'm done I said okay and then here
comes I said not luckily I had olive on
I said no first place yep three minutes
later he walks by goes I'm out excuse me
you think guys were taken says out I had
seen Oh Martinez to play there and yeah
I can remember every pitch we had to
steal on a Paris we had to pitch
everybody he gave it up god bless that
thing I remember about rainy Johnson it
just hit Jim Larson
with a fastball we had a big brouhaha
and I'm on the stage and Houston happens
our starting pitcher that was
uncomfortable okay walk me through that
one more time mother I remember anything
part that walked me through that one one
more time we just played the Mariners
right yeah next ball laris which a lot
of people seem to try to do and yeah we
had a pretty good skirmish and then you
know two or three days later you sit
down stage where they're trying to act
like you know I had Randy later
obviously got the knowing but the
competitive part of you want to know
part of being on that side he wasn't but
he did what you had to do he had oh my
well put on quite a show that's for
those were the starting pitchers that
night huh him and I remember and of
course buck no come on now of course you
know I mean it was a big night big
absolutely big night what did you think
of last night's game buck did you you
know you're through man I watched it
okay of course I did
I know I watched most of it is you know
I love that part of it it's a difference
you know it's a different game pitching
it always is better than hitting you
know when the hitters are at the top of
their game and pitchers at the top of
the game pitching gonna win especially
with approach that hitters have today to
hitting not saying it's wrong or right
you know listen to Smoltz Johnson also
really good analyst conjuring does a
good job I agree there's some up some up
quite frankly I can't listen to it but
he is he's solid and he actually you
know remembers how hard the game was to
play and how bad he was on a given I
sometimes these guys forget you know you
think they never made a mistake on the
field but he it was good yes obviously
said 20 our last 23 American League has
won yeah right 19 of the last 23 yeah
because well I mean it doesn't one of
them was a tie so yeah people on the
field I'll tell you the leagues are
different they are you know in a World
Series seven games to three pitchers get
hot any league can win but the teams are
constructed so differently in the two
leagues that when you play interleague
play whatever there is a difference in
the two leagues RIT's trust me well and
the difference is as simple as a pitcher
pitches in one in hits and one and
doesn't and the other is it is it that
simple it's a difference
the [ __ ] in the ditches in America
are completely different than not
nationally you gotta have a lot of guys
who can play a lot of positions and can
run it and American League you have so
many weapons coming off the bench and
you're just taking your poison as a
manager at the matchups but actually
these are managing the American League
in today's game and some people might be
surprised by the most people have
managed it both we will tell you that
well the thing here's the thing
buck-buck show up to three time al
manage of the year here on the Rich
Eisen show you know it seems to me you
know right now that the analytics tells
kids swing as hard as you possibly can
that's the way to you can get in the
major leagues is we're talking about
exit velocity and that shift right there
way to beat it is just hit it over their
heads and just swing as hard as you can
I mean were you seeing that sort of
shift if you will towards the end of
your tenure or during your tenure most
recently in Baltimore
oh sure sure you know there's a whole
lot new going on him but it's not the
players fault rich don't be mad the
players you know they're they're gonna
chase the or the dollar fall and when
guys are getting big arbitration awards
and raises we're starting out 180 times
here and it's 25 more months it's not
their fault you know that it's being
embraced so the players not the players
fall this is the way that they're you
know they know that they're deemed is
being successful and still the teams
that defendants are the ones that are
playing at the end and you look at all
the good to answer people just about the
Red Sox last year how great they were
defensively the Yankees are gonna get
this year Dodgers afraid offensively and
it's just so much more creeping on the
ball to stay in a ballpark you got to
catch them but you know it comes into
play I mean I'd go two or three weeks
without putting a sign on last year now
we didn't have a lot of baserunners like
tell you that but you know the hit and
run I mean how many people can you trust
to put the ball in play I mean trust
people can you trust a steel base those
skills aren't embraced as much anymore
and why I'm saying it's right or wrong
I've got personal feelings about it but
you know it's because they're chasing
the dollar that's where the dollar is
RIT's way of really business runs in
general but why is it
you know even even Verlander who said
that the the balls were juiced and
purposefully juiced willfully and
someone's not sitting in a bad scientist
we're gonna say hey let's do this and
nobody will find out I don't I keep a
secret base are you kidding
everybody knows everybody signs and what
they're using so it's just you know
that's that's not true but yeah the
balls are being made better cars are
being made better medicines being a
better closer being nice better yeah it
is but even even the reason why I guess
I brought that up was even Verlander
said he thought that at some point and
Smoltz said it when he was on this show
yesterday Buck Showalter that uh that at
some point the pendulum will swing back
and there will be a premium placed on
hitting the ball the other way
on making contact on the stuff that you
just said that causes you not to even
put on a sign because not enough people
can can be trusted to put balls into
play how does that happen you knowing
the the machinations of a front office
and what they put the premium on in
dollar signs for how does that happen
but well they're gonna put the premium
on what allows you won games that's not
what GM's are judged on and the
entertainment value is another part of
it you know as long as the TV contracts
are there in their embracing of Major
League Baseball they're going to
continue down a path but when you know I
don't want him opponent come to the town
we're buddies watch this game at home
nobody's at the ballpark we've made it
so easy so people stay at home and watch
on TV we really have when you set your
recorder you record it you walk out of
the room you come back you go on wait a
minute I want to get in a car and drive
down find a place to port you know it's
chops so yeah it'll continue down this
path I hear but on my Oh it'll come back
around
sure it will a lot of because of
leadership in the front office's are
embracing this because it kind of fits
their skillset a lot more so yeah until
some of the fathers or some of the
leadership groups the ownership and
whatever I decide that you know
something else is in boat so to speak or
there's a better way to do it and then
they'll be some copycats that I don't
see it close by I not I got some of the
best most quality baseball people
my owner sitting at home without jobs
that's kind of sad but and I do think
they're making more mistakes on player
evaluation any time I can ever remember
because there's not a lot of front
offices that can evaluate the six tool
so it'd be interesting to watch hmm how
would you fix it well you need to you
need to embrace all parts of it rich
you've got to have and we're doing
analytics back in the eighties and
nineties this isn't something to do they
just got a lot more at-bats and lightwei
federal ways to bring up the numbers and
the tendencies that you've got to
embrace the people on the phone the
boots on the ground you've got to
embrace the analytics and the people
that are the best at it
Boston New York come to mind because I
know how strongly they are in both areas
they make good evaluations on makeup
because it's so important playing in
Boston in New York to have people with
certain makeup that can survive there so
you embrace all departments and not put
one above the other one you bring in all
parts of information those are the teams
that really make good player decisions
buck showalter here in the Rich Eisen
show ya yo you okay over there bunk
everything good yeah the team you put
your marker on to win this year's World
Series right now as we're getting set
for the second part of the season we uh
you know III like the little engine that
could mentality of a Minnesota twin club
they play in a great ballpark to put
anybody hadn't been there that's one of
the best parts of baseball they do a
great job there it's really it's typical
Minnesota I love the Yankees I think
that they've done a great job of makeup
and their what-ifs are now coming from
their minor-league system as opposed to
having to go take somebody else they
always have the word - you know - go get
somebody that they need and they're able
to withstand injuries but you know you
look at the depth because with the
ten-day deal there so I guess you know
how base but he I just I like the way
that the beings have put together their
clubs there's a great mentality around
Ezard and so doing the great signing so
they all season was Nelson Cruz there -
OH - putting him and John scope together
was great
would you would you push the push the
button pull the trigger on Madison
Bumgarner for the Yankees if something
like that is available and it would cost
you obviously
you're planning for October right now if
you're the Yankees would you would you
pull the trigger on something like that
of course if he was available you know I
don't know you don't know what the
asking price is right I mean would you
trade glide were tourists four months
ago for him no you wouldn't is there
someone sitting there like that you know
they just find one of the best Latin
American and I free agents I'm 67 year
old kid supposedly ever would you give
him up for him and those are the
questions that there'd be an ass right
now because believe me the dice are to
ask it for jokes Moe by the way I divide
these ideas baseball card about 15 times
Joe Schmoe good old Joe Schmo cards the
other day rich
what what what uh before I let you go
buck give me a good Deon story you got a
good one oh gosh uh inside-the-park home
run hey look that up sometime you don't
like people say what you're my top three
most exciting office ever I'm coach at
third base you're he and Bojack are John
back at for both getting on camera and
he's playing centerfield for Kansas City
beyond playing centerfield for us and
they're John back and forth before the
series start see you know see on can't
tackle he can outrun though back and
forth this games pretty ugly field
remember so the game starts out Bogut's
home run its first two at-bats yeah yes
bombs it makes a great catch and I could
tell it the fianc kind of down I'd had
him in Albany a couple years before
double-a we've got pretty close to the
fact he's still anyway I'll shorten it
up look he goes no hurt go let's go
let's go let's go anyway
he hit the ball in the right centerfield
pull it up sometimes it's alright we
just showed it will show it again as you
tell the story go forward yeah go for it
yeah no my crews good my crews good
right centerfield he comes around so
you've got the Jheri curls working
everything now bodachs is ball separates
his shoulders I think South the rest of
season somebody knows that part of and
he's starting to shut it down around
second put the chicken flap down and
pushed in the third nobody could run a
triple out like yeah and we haven't
scored a run in a month with that team
and he comes around third I start
pumping him to getting gold he's good
local employees like oh my god this
crazy guys get me so here we go
we're coming McFarland I think the
catcher there's a relay coming from my
event biancalana I'm not sure he's out
by about to step whatever but they
shorted out the catcher he blocks the
ball durwood Merill is on part the hook
techniques now beyond jumps over the
catcher comes back in matter can he get
his hand on the plate before McFarland
can retrieve the ball and put it on top
of him he's safe by a finger
Oh show you up like that you got your
shot there and you took it because dang
you're serious I know man every baseball
team he played on the my league he was
loved guy I know I'm a they still he
still does I mean he'll but his face
will light up when you talk handle
Hensley mule ins with them you told when
you talk Bam Bam with them and I believe
play tomorrow it's one greatest athletes
I've ever thought ever seen anybody
running like that home I'm sorry first
and second on salt but if you don't look
wait for the ball got the home plate now
run the ball he's the breathtaking speed
ok by the way
Brockman get say that again it's the 20
what what anniversaries of that play
we're a week away from the 29th
anniversary July 17th 1990 well you did
that's for sure and I'm sure Dion I
think that that was in his 30 for 30
also they talked about that with Bo and
that one really is silence with
everybody
clubhouse actors everybody left and he
leans over next to man we're talking
about to play priceless and that's
expecting there is not the other man
ever put up with not bad
all right man look the [ __ ] are you
doing stuff for yes network is that what
you're gonna start doing really good
people I really like I know a lot of
people they're starting to start on the
lumps and see where it takes me
i watch it all the time with my watch it
all the time with my kids out here on
the left coast watching Yankee baseball
I'm
watch Tunney yes I look forward to
seeing you on there you better get some
sleep I got to keep up with you thanks
to the car we'll chat soon you got that
so that's Buck Showalter you four more
of the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 under red TV for free on VR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app